the National Archive says 5 400 Biden
emails where he's using fake names and
according to a lawsuit he's using these
to engage in illicit business dealings
with his son Hunter we've known about
some of these aliases for quite a while
now and they were through government
addresses I think this shows at this
point it's almost pointless to even
bring up because we all know Joe Biden
was doing this we all know he was
influence peddling we all all know
Hunter Biden was engaged in business
dealings overseas we all know that
Donald Trump was trying to expose this
and for that they impeached him but I
guess with this new information coming
out and Nara saying that they can't just
release these records quite yet we
should at least address the news we'll
talk about that plus one of my favorite
stories of the day Rachel Maddow says
that Donald Trump if he wins will
probably be president for life and she's
not wrong
because Donald Trump is nearly the
average life expectancy so for life
means probably one more term let's be
real I I wish the president uh uh best
of health but no she literally means
they'll be presents like 100 years old
because these people live in a crazy
crackpot reality where Russia could turn
off your electricity in the middle of
winter and you'll die so we'll talk
about that and then this very viral
story 12 year old boy had a Gadsden flag
patch and so his school removed him
saying that the Gadsden flag is
associated with slavery so you can't
have it we'll be getting into those
stories before we do my friends head
over to timcast.com click join us join
us as a member at timcast.com join
timgas.com to to support us directly but
also to check out the members only
uncensored show that we put up Monday
through Thursday at 10 pm
as a member you'll get access to these
segments a massive library of all our
past segments and you can submit
questions and even call in to talk to us
live on the uncensored show you got to
sign up for at least six months or sign
up at the 25 per month level it's kind
of a screener we do to make sure that
we're not getting crackpots and Weirdos
trying to come in and just cause US
problems but it is available to you so
please consider signing up and joining
us but also if you go to timcast.com you
can click timcast IRL X Miami if you
want to watch me and lucrutkowski host a
show with Patrick Bet David Donald Trump
Jr and Matt Gates get your tickets now
we've sold I think about 130 or so of
800 and this just launched last week so
we're probably looking at another week
or so of availability the first event we
did had only around I think like 100 to
200 tickets and we saw those about a day
or two so it looks like we're tracking
comparably at the at this rate of sales
we did a bigger venue and uh hopefully
we will see you all there it should be
fun there's going to be a pre-show and
there's going to be an after show with q
a and all that stuff it's going to be
awesome really excited this will be
October 6th go to timcast.com pick up
your tickets now also don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show right now
wherever you can if you really do want
to help Word of Mouth really helps
podcasts grow you can follow the show at
timcastirl joining us tonight to talk
about this and so much more is Nick
sorter
how are you doing Tim you want to grab
your microphone I should grab my
microphone yeah microphone would help
who are you what do you do uh I'm an
independent journalist I am uh somebody
that covers stories that you don't
really see in the mainstream media uh it
seems like a lot of them have a a you
know a narrative maybe they're that
they're pushing based on you know
another entity or political agenda this
political agenda and so you know
basically I go to places like East
Palestine Ohio I was in Maui last week
uh covering the fires out there because
you know somebody somebody has to hold
the government accountable here because
uh you know it seems like for years and
years there was
you have all these corporate media
outlets and you didn't hear a lot of
these stories and this stuff isn't new
when it comes to government cover-ups
and stuff but you're the universe
actually they protect them they protect
them absolutely they protect them so I'm
glad that we finally have a platform you
know such as x that you know we can kind
of broadcast this stuff out to and uh
and you know it scares these government
officials so and we're gonna keep on
with that right on well we'll uh we'll
definitely jump into the Hawaii stuff so
thanks very much should be a blast
absolutely we got Hannah Claire hanging
out hey I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com it's the best new
site of all time in my personal opinion
answer too hi everyone Ian cross and I'm
back we finished the music video this
last weekend it was incredible and uh
I'm looking forward to tonight's show as
well I've been listening on the road a
little bit I mean you guys holding down
the fort while I'm gone to the best
weekend it's a lot of fun yeah Libby was
he in yesterday that was a good show man
Spike Cohen sounds like me I was like it
sounds like I'm talking right now the
spikes but he's just got a lot more
information about economics yeah and uh
we got Kellen press on the buttons
that's right uh I'm pushing buttons this
week while surge is in uh Sunny Miami
getting everything ready for that
awesome event so uh let's get started
guys here's the story from the New York
Post National Archives has 5 400 Biden
emails in which he uses fake names to
Dish government info to Hunter and
others as VP that's a general idea he is
engaging illicit business dealings by
giving private information to his son
who then acts as his proxy and now we're
hearing this is the breaking news from
today the National Archive quote drags
its heels on the release of these
records related to Biden's pseudonyms
after a 2022 foia request
they say from the post millennial the
National Archives and Records
Administration revealed on Monday that
it is in possession of around 5 400
documents this we know the group's
request
this is Southeastern Legal Foundation
sought emails related to the accounts of
jrb Ware robinware and Robert L Peters
pseudonyms that Biden was known to use
during his time as vice president the
foundation filed on Monday against Nara
for the release of the records claiming
that these records may show that Biden
forwarded government information and
discussed government business with
Hunter by as well as others I think the
general idea is he did do that and there
are emails in which Hunter Biden is cc'd
where government information is being
given out quote all too often public
officials abuse their power by using it
for their personal or political benefit
when they do many seek to hide it the
only way to preserve government
governmental Integrity is for Nara to
release Biden's nearly five five
thousand four hundred emails to slf and
thus the public the American people
deserves to know what is in them said
Kimberly Herman slf general counsel okay
they're accusing Nara of dragging its
heels saying that they can't just
release them right yet uh right right as
of yet but um I got I gotta be honest
you know while this is
it should be really big news we've right
we had the Victor shoken Story come out
last week he gives an interview he
actually says yes I was fired because
the bidens you asked do you think
they're getting bribes like yes I do he
also has a sworn this is the prosecutor
and you can also also has a sworn
affidavit saying he was fired because of
Joe Biden now we know
you've got these records potential
strong evidence that Biden was doing
exactly what he thought he was doing and
at a certain point is it just like
shrug I guess what do we do well this is
no surprise to Nara either okay because
I mean they've had this for years keep
in mind Joe Biden was vice president up
until you know early 2017 January 2017
and you know you have to think that Nora
was the organization that ended up
pursuing Donald Trump over the
quote-unquote classified documents
Scandal and you know so it's not like
plenty of time hasn't elapsed for Nara
to come out and and and kind of raise a
flag over this if they are the
presidential record keepers
how come they didn't come out with this
back in 2017 or earlier let's just add
them to the list of corrupt government
entities that are lying and manipulating
the American public for the benefit of
the democratic party right yeah I don't
think anyone would have assumed they
were crap I don't think anyone thinks
about them that much but this is the
time or have heard of them that's
exactly right when uh the Mar-A-Lago
raid happened I'm sure everyone was like
Googling this organization saying what
do they do again but it's important and
you can see now where you get these
organizations that kind of operate in
the background and get to be corrupt
over time because no one knows to keep
them accountable I mean that is one of
the downsides of having such a massive
government right we can't look at every
place all the time all at once it's so
wild to pull back the curtain and see
how corrupt this government that we have
that we've been a part of living off of
for for me 44 years is like how do we
deal with that now it's like it's just
Global resolve now we have to decide how
are we going to deal with the fact that
so many leaders and processes in our
system that we benefit from are
corrupted how do we do it because we
can't just make it end then we all die
that's the end you know you don't end it
you have to do something and you start
arresting them one by it's never
happened but like what do we do never
happen until it's happening in front of
everyone in on Earth compromise maybe we
don't arrest them
we send them to Alaska I think that was
vivek's plan right I feel like Alaska
doesn't deserve that you know they're
doing nothing wrong that is true that we
have enough geographical challenges they
don't have all the sunlight I have to be
honest if I worked like if I was working
for the government they were like you're
being resigned to Alaska to be like cool
that sounds awesome right you're like go
fishing and polar bears and waterfalls
whatever just far enough away
but no I think that wasn't a vague's
plan like reassign the FBI and just
spread them all over into weird places
yeah he wants to move into the uh Army
the marshals the U.S Marshals and two
other organizations within the
government I I I I agree with you Ian
and that's kind of the point I'm getting
to
with this story you know I read this the
other day and I read today that they're
dragging their heels or whatever they're
not going to release this and I'm just
like
how do I feel enthusiastic or shocked by
this news to the point where I'm just
like Heaven's me I must inform the
people I'm more like well yeah what else
is new I think that's playing to Joe
Biden's uh Advantage right the fact that
we all know they're corrupt so we're
like this is interesting information
that we all already feel like it's
interesting adding to the pile here
right you know it's like we're we're
coming to the point where you have James
Comer who is the the house oversight
committee chair that keeps coming up
with more and more and more information
but it's like okay yep just it's well
and Biden on the on the campaign Trail
in 2019 said you know there's there was
no hint of Scandal when when I was in
the white house and I specifically never
asked my son her brother about their
business dealings which is interesting
because number one I feel like that's
sort of unrealistic you're you're his
father and you never ask him anything
about it Peters asked it wasn't uh oh
that's true I forgot it's gonna be funny
that there's like a guy appears on stage
who looks kind of like Biden and his
name is Robert Peters
real person you know the Biden by Dan
conspiracy
I've vaguely heard of it you've never
seen the Biden by Dan no come on are you
guys you guys Tim you're better being on
the internet than the rest of us I
apparently am because it's one of the
funniest conspiracy theories ever let me
yeah the body double one yes oh okay
yeah here you go that's what I do I
don't know is this yeah
he did go through a nasty transformation
you got a bunch of plastic surgery
facelift right that's more than that
look at his nose he got he got a bunch
of work I missed the old Biden that old
curmudgeon on the left the one that
hated crack cocaine yeah
people have asked me like how hey Nick
how has how did Joe Biden's earlobe
become attached all of a sudden when it
was it was on a dashboard you know yeah
I I think his face left first it's
really funny when that video that the
photo came out where it was like Hillary
Clinton goes to a thing you know an
event and everyone's like that does not
look like Hillary Clinton it kind of did
but didn't and then the corporate press
was like conspiracy theorists think
there's a body double yo they all have
body doubles for sure why not in fact
they all do it is like basic security
protocol to have a body double not even
like like dude in movies actors have
stunt doubles you think that world
leaders who are fearing for their
safeties they travel abroad and go out
in public don't have body doubles now
I'm not saying Biden by Dan or whatever
is or isn't I'm just saying that we can
agree on they do and it's absurd to
think they don't as to whether or not
they replaced Joe Biden with another guy
named baidan I think is ridiculous and I
think there's a much simpler solution
all I got to do is look at a picture of
Madonna before and after and be like how
did Madonna's face get so swollen how
did how'd her lips get so big how did
her nose get so small it's like well
dude she's getting plastic surgery do
you want number one Kamala dropped out
of the race and then kind of went dark
for a minute and then she came back to
do some TV interview and she had clearly
had a facelift and that's when everyone
was like oh she's gonna be VP because
she just went and got this work done is
that why she was going to become VP are
we 100 I think that was the confirmation
she had been asked to be EP
I love conspiracy theories because it's
just for a moment allows you to escape
reality and imagine you're in an action
movie unfortunately people I gotta tell
you life is actually much more boring
and routine than that and it's it's it's
it's just never as crazy as you think
that's but is it though because all
these conspiracy theories that we keep
hearing about you know with covet and
such it it you know everybody that was
called a conspiracy those are the those
are like I think those are the
conspiracy theories people joke about
those are the cons like when you talk
about Wuhan lab for instance that's
because someone went hey a virus emerged
in a city with his with his lab where
they're doing coronavirus research and
then the media called you a conspiracy
theorist even though your hypothesis is
based in reality and quite likely very
probable I'm talking about Joe Biden
being replaced look at this one I love
this I'm talking about the hilarious
conspiracy theories like Joe Biden being
replaced by a body double named by Dan
and I don't even know what it's because
Trump called him by Dan that's where the
name comes from Trump said uh I have
confidence that chairman Kim will keep
his promise to me and also smiled when
he called Swamp Man Joe bidan a low IQ
individual so now people are saying
they're different people look it's it's
really dude got a facelift he got a
bunch of plastic surgery look at his
hair it's just it's they do it I don't
know or fine whatever you could C-SPAN
said he's a different guy he looks
different fine whatever believe whatever
you want I was were you gonna say
something oh I was gonna say there was a
whole period during the beginning
presidency where he would go to Delaware
on the weekends and he'd wear his big
aviators and ask and he and Joe would be
out like doing whatever they're supposed
to be doing and they wouldn't hold hands
and that's when I was like oh I wouldn't
be surprised if they have a body double
because if you are extremely worried
about the oldest president in the U.S
potentially Contracting you know a virus
maybe you wouldn't want him to send send
him to crowded places like there is a
version of this where I could see
a spin that would make sense I don't
actually know that it wasn't him it just
seemed like a plausible explanation that
our sweet sweet White House Press
Secretary might offer at some point I
thought it was you brought up kovid
that's fascinating I was just thinking
that when you talk about people think
that life is like a movie and it's going
to be as exciting as a movie dude we had
a bio weapon leak everyone thought it
was going to be like the stand that
Stephen King movie or leak or release no
one knows but we'll slow down a little
bit and say buy a weapon conjecture
perhaps gain of function research simply
put yeah whether or not they were
weaponizing it I don't know how what
terminology essentially they a lab uh
virus is being worked on it got out
people were expecting it to be like
bloody faces people the hospitals will
be overloaded so they overreacted they
were like mandates shut down this and
that hospitals got whacked a little bit
but we we persisted because it's real
life the human body is meant to persist
we're now living with covid it's part of
our environment now it's part like the
flu the influenza like yeah it's endemic
it's now it's with us forever it will be
with us unless and it will always be
mutating with us there's no need to
panic anymore now we're living with it I
think is there is there a phrase to
describe uh the
belief that things are like movies you
know what I mean uh so Elon Musk says
that the most entertaining outcome is
the most likely and it seems like that
makes more and more sense as time goes
on I I think it's a funny joke I don't
think it's true I think
the most routine outcome the most boring
actually tends to be the the the
simplest and people want it to be the
most entertaining outcome they say that
because there's been a handful of
instances where we've laughed about
what's going on but uh uh you know back
to what you're saying about covid people
watch movies then think this is how
things are and then expect real life to
be that way like the sound of guns for
instance I love the sound of punches in
movies it's almost like a little
miniature explode yeah right like that
does not sound like that at all and guns
don't sound like that and especially
like one one easy and simple example is
like in Netflix for instance this woman
has it's the new episode of Black Mirror
and she has an AI uh making a story out
of her life by protect doing all of her
behaviors and she goes to her Lauren the
Lord's like I'm sorry the contract is
Ironclad there's nothing you can do and
then people think that's true people
think that if you send a contract with
someone the judge is gonna go well you
signed it no they're just gonna be like
one of the terms and why are they
written okay that makes no sense
contracts dissolved judge can literally
just tear it up in court and be like it
means nothing to me the movies movie
stuff is not real but I'm what I was
asking I'm wondering is there a way is
there a phrase for describing this uh uh
what would you call it a bias movie bias
maybe it's like the belief that things
uh are uh fictionalized when in real
life they're actually much more boring
the closest thing what you're saying has
made me think of is uh the idea that
after the movie The Truman Show came out
people started saying I feel like that's
happening to me and that's sort of it's
it's not an actual term The Truman
effect is sort of what I feel like
you're describing in some respects
because people feel like they they
consume so much media that in some ways
they start transplanting the concepts or
the bounds of that reality into their
own life but the the thing about the
Truman effect is that it's actually just
a renaming of gang stalking do you guys
know what gang stalking is there's a uh
uh people who suffer from psychological
delusions one of them I don't know what
it's called but they believe they're
being stalked and followed by everybody
and so they'll be walking down the
street and someone will look at them and
they'll go and they'll be like you're
following me and then they'll say look
at a car and they'll see someone in the
car look at them it's like well yeah
when you look at someone's face they'll
look at you be like why are they looking
at me but then the person whose
delusional thinks that everyone is
stalking you're the paranoia you take
that already in existence create The
Truman Show then people who are
predisposed to have these kind of gang
stalking delusions now think I'm in The
Truman Show they're all filming me that
explains I think that term could be
synephasm if you're a belief that uh
reality is like a movie is that what
it's called well did you make that I
just made that up that's the sinner
being from Cinema and then phasm meaning
what is this Greek for meaning like a
light and extreme belief or something
phasma Apparition Phantom so it's like
this belief this like false belief in
the reality of a film
yeah I don't know I I feel like it's a
bias or something like it's a it's it's
a fiction a script bias or something
where people believe that real life will
play out like movies or that the movie
scenario is the more likely scenario
when really the most boring scenario
tends to be like the most routine I I
guess yeah
it's in line with Occam's razor The
Simple Solution tends to be the correct
one and so or how about when you hear
Hooves think horses not zebras but
people will get in there and change it
so like water flowing down a mountain
it'll take the path of least resistance
so so do so too does reality but people
will get in there and create little
blocks and dams of like well I'm the one
in control so you have to be here on
this day and all of a sudden least
resistance has a new definition when
people tweak the system well let's jump
to the story speaking of people who are
suffering serious delusions Rachel
Maddow worries Trump will probably will
be probably president for life if he
wins in 2024. and I said BC host notes
and the current political movement
far-right politics is coinciding with
far-right violence it's a lie they just
have to say it I I have to wonder
you know there are a lot of evil people
out there I like you know what's going
on in uh how do you pronounce it
shinjang and uh with the with the uyghur
Muslim camps yeah that's evil stuff
right the forced abortions like
nightmarishly evil Rachel Maddow is a
kind of evil you know but I wouldn't put
her anywhere near like genocide level
but pretty evil in that she goes on her
show and says things that any sane
person even a liberal electus would know
is just crackpot psychotic nonsense but
she says it anyway because she gets a
lot of ratings I mean she she was the
highest rated uh uh Caster on on MSNBC
you know and so she made a lot of money
off of it she got huge ratings and she
continues to Parrot these just I mean
crazy ludicrous narratives like yeah
Donald Trump and she was one of the
biggest proponents of the whole Russia
hoax and you know and she continues to
parrot that to this day even though it's
been debunked over and over because she
has a monetary incentive absolutely
right there's no reason she started
seeing like guys I've changed my mind
not the case her ratings would probably
collapse all of the the uh the attention
that her show gets would go away in some
cases the way our media works it
incentivizes people to get more and more
crazy I mean we see this YouTube is the
same exactly we see an independent media
all the time the people will start
saying more outlandish things I mean
let's think of like the clip 80
thumbnails that people put out they
might need to because it drives people
to their channel on the other hand like
are they always super accurate no
I think with Rachel Maddow what's
interesting is there is an actual
hysteria and fear Underneath It All she
really does seem to be personally
panicked about Trump's influence on the
country you don't think so absolutely if
you watch it it looks like she's just
saying garble now the clip we should
pull it up let's just I'll show you a
bit of it this morning heading into what
we knew would be two big important Court
hearings on these Trump cases today in
federal court in Georgia and federal
court indeed probably what he was
planning probably what he's thinking but
per the New York Times it does seem sort
of significant that that's what he's now
telling people
that's what he's telling people he's
gonna do he will solve his jumble of
legal problems by winning the election
and you know whatever you think about
that
that's how he's thinking about that okay
and what does that say about the
election for all of the rest of us right
it means in his own mind and those of
his campaign and his supporters
presumably these are the stakes
and again whatever you think about that
as a legal strategy for Trump that is
how he is thinking about the election
how many times was he going to say the
same thing over and over again just
there you know what I said I think four
times Trump's strategy to get rid of his
legal problems is to win the election
think about that what does that what do
you think that means it does what do you
think it means no no the point is Rachel
Maddow has no passion and is saying
literally nothing she is pattering she
is speaking words with no meaning to
extend time the thing she is saying
exists only in I gotta get through this
hour and then I'm going to have lunch
with the girls I would love to get her
off script and interview her she's not
on script she's probably just
means one of two things
if this is the way he's going to
approach it we should keep saying it
over and over again he loses the
election and he can't go into specifics
because she doesn't actually understand
and if she brought out any actual facts
and is that for life that he gets to be
president will we keep having more
elections or no
if every election is a new opportunity
for him to go to prison do you think he
allows us to have new elections what
does that mean this is total fear
mongering nobody believes that there is
no Avenue for Donald Trump to possibly
be able to suspend elections what's he
gonna do suspend the Constitution to to
make it so that he's president for Life
nobody actually believes that so she's
clearly look in that minute she said I
think maybe like 15 different words she
explained nothing and she said over and
over and over again what you think about
what Trump thinks that means Trump
thinks this and no matter what you think
that means Trump means this which means
in the election Trump will think this
and isn't teleporters this that means
whatever you think Trump thinks this
like did she okay at all how he would do
that did she explain that at all well of
course not no she doesn't believe that
she can't evilness she doesn't believe
anything she's saying she's not actually
saying anything and she this is this
this is the challenge you know I think
about you got the world economic forum
you will own nothing and you'll be happy
and you had these video clips where
parents are like my baby is you know
gonna get the the medication we're gonna
sterilize the kid and stuff like that
and I'm just like at a certain point
what do you do when you're watching
Lemmings I mean this figuratively when
you're watching them walk off a cliff
now I know Disney forced them off a
cliff with a broom yeah I'm making a
point yeah Lemmings don't actually walk
off cliffs like that yeah the Disney
producers shoved them off with brooms
like get out of here we're gonna film it
and make money off you but it's actually
a good example of what this people are
mindlessly Marching towards their own
demise do you step in I mean we've been
trying you are we are this show is doing
that but not everyone's gonna listen you
just can't grab them by the throat and
and pull them back or you'll be
considered the aggressor you've got to
let them go yeah so we're watching we're
watching them March toward the cliff and
we're going stop please please don't do
it and they're like you're so crazy
they're going off the ratings Cliff
though I mean like hey come on who
watches MSNBC at this point I mean so
it's on hotels and things I saw Chuck
Todd over the weekend and this is pretty
funny I was listening to Chuck Todd and
he was like the thing about Trump's
election lies are and I was like dude
election claims call them claims don't
make the assumption that they're like it
was just to purport that it was a lie
without it it was it's to make sure that
you already know to be on guard to
whatever Trump is yeah it was a
tribalist like a tribalist flag being
raised like if you're part of our group
we all know wink wink that he's that's a
lie anyway so an Acclaim might imply
that there's some credit to them which
they cannot allow right there can't be
any reason why he would be right in any
way yeah it was a neutral would have
been a neutral statement was to say talk
about his claims as opposed to uh Rachel
got 3.9 million viewers the number one
show across all of Television including
broadcast wow she's getting on Fox News
well I mean of course they beat up Fox
News they fired Tucker I mean what I
mean sure but this is right yeah no one
else but this is the point
this is it Rachel Maddow is going to say
next thing she like President Trump will
be president for Life Next thing she's
going to come out and she's gonna start
she's got to increase it now she's going
to come out and be alike well Trump's
going to start rounding people up and
then she's going to talk about trains
and then she's going to talk about
whatever it is that's going to terrify
people and convince them they have to
watch glued to it like some kind of
disgusting drug I think she doesn't
realize the power she has as an
individual the people that are afraid of
Donald Trump that are afraid of some
external power don't realize the amount
of power they have within their own
Community to prevent and buffer from
that stuff yeah but I think she wants it
right like if if she is the most popular
show on television right now and she
gets to scare you and so you come back
to listen to her every day to say Rachel
what what should I know you you're
telling me all these awful things you're
really insightful you know she knows she
has influence she knows she has power I
think that's why she can present in a
monologue like this that references
nothing she repeats the same phrase over
and over again she doesn't cite any
facts she's not like because in this law
would allow him to whoever she's just
speculating knowing that people will be
afraid of it and then we're taking on
confirmation bias that's it that's all
she's doing and she's good at it meaning
that she's assuming that her audience
already believes her premise absolutely
absolutely they do I mean in my opinion
that is the reason that she is pulling
you know three point something million
viewers uh on her her episode I believe
she only does like two or three episodes
a week at this point she somehow gets
away with that because you know she does
have a lot of power no but nobody
watches any other Show on MSNBC she's
retired soon yeah she checked out a long
time ago I mean come on you go to any
person how old is she someone look
apologies yeah look it up was she like
her mid late 40s I don't think she might
even be older than that really she's
been around for a long time born in 73
so that would make her 50 48 currently
48. 73 born on April 1st happy April
Fool's Day Rachel one day before me she
was born in 1973 yeah April 1st 1973.
this should be 50. yes so she's 48 no so
she'd be 50. 50.
no 48 she'll be
what year I mean 49 yeah because your
birthday's in April okay so she'll be 15
1974. no she'd still be 50. so this
probably looks out of date she says
she's either way yeah she'd be 50. she's
up there
sorry for all the 50 plus year olds out
there that is really weird anyway she's
retired man I'm saying 48 years old on
this since she was born April 1st 1973.
it's like the table what are you looking
at let's just
is going to feed us such trash for the
next two decades but what was the
argument we knew when her her birth year
was like a bro she's 50. it was like
turn right now you're wrong the ocean's
right there I'm gonna turn right okay
anyway the point is she's retired she's
50 and they went to her and said what
are you doing and she goes I just want
to go to sleep I'm just so tired and sad
and pathetic and they're like we'll give
you five million dollars to do a show
once a week I guess fine
that's what she's doing that's why she's
patterning on the show that's why she's
just she's she's going like Donald Trump
wants to be president that means he'll
run for president and no matter what you
think about that he's gonna tell his
supporters he's running for president so
you might not want to be president but
he's gonna run and you know what that
means he'll tell his supporters he's
running no matter what it is you think
that's literally what she did
off the offer wild also she's getting
paid millions of dollars to do this like
what a sweet gig guys I don't know what
to tell you what are they gonna do fire
her I mean if MSNBC doesn't have a
network without Rachel maddowell I
couldn't name another uh MSNBC host to
be honest with you I mean Chris Matthews
I mean I can see it right here no he got
fired actually because he said something
uh sexist or right right right
um Chris Hayes uh Chris Hayes is he is
he also Chris Hayes uh but Chuck Todd
Chuck Todd's uh NBC yeah MSNBC is Chris
Hayes all right you got one good point
um I have the feeling oh I don't know um
oh Brian Brian Williams right because he
got fired for being a lion yeah he said
he was in an Apache helicopter or
whatever being shot by sniper fire so we
were all surprised to learn that a guy
on cable TV news was lying to us and
then they fired him and then MSNBC was
like he's our guy that's right that's
right sounds great I wonder if Rachel
goes home at night and is like I hate
this job I do not want to even think
about politics but she's getting paid 15
million dollars uh what a year or what's
this yeah probably something like just
go repeat the crap I think you're
overlooking like the social position 20
million 20 million she's getting paid 20
million dollars to barely say anything
four million dollars to go on TV
she doesn't have to memorize any hard
information I can't even believe that
she like there's no way there's a script
there but also everyone wants to invite
her to things and have her places like
there is a social currency that she
knows she has I think she wouldn't give
up this job even though she's not
passionate about it if she started a new
show that was less political I think
she'd still have a lot of followers I
think you can't really step away from
that Prestige like I think there is sort
of something to being the like the
female I don't personally agree with it
but I think she has been told you know
this you're this uh high-powered female
political commentator you have your own
show it would be harder for her to
transition to like something like Oprah
did where she just like goes around
interviewing people I think there's an
ego part to it not that she should feel
ashamed of it but what happened to
Hillary Clinton had her show did that do
well is it canceled because I think
that's a good yeah she got her own show
on a major streaming platform where
she's gonna like interview other
high-profile women and stuff and they're
gonna paint and stuff what I'm wondering
is that would be a good kind of like
thing to check to see how well Mata
would do on her own what's up what's up
with all these left-wing people painting
nowadays I mean is it there's just so
much money in painting and George blush
too well Jordan well I guess George well
I mean he's not too right at this point
I don't know but you see Hunter Biden
you know he's now painting again he was
doing it before but he's now painting
again and paying and fifteen thousand
six hundred dollars per month in rent
but he can't pay child support for the
uh the granddaughter that they just
decided they acknowledged yeah no they
just decided to acknowledge yep he's not
paying child support for the kid no he
is well it's the they're going to court
over it though because he doesn't want
to so no it got settled he's paying he's
paying child support into it do you know
how much uh I don't because it's not
disclosed the big thing was that he had
a child support agreement he was trying
to get out of it because he stopped
making as much money he said so he's
like I should it should be readjusted
it's just something people do all the
time and then also on top of that he
started arguing the the child's mother
said well my child should get to use the
Biden last name because it's a prominent
last name in the U.S it could
potentially open doors for her and he
was fighting really hard to stop that uh
that's good I believe Joe Biden kept
saying well I have six grandchildren and
you know in reality he had seven and he
just refused to acknowledge the seventh
grandchild
um you know until like what a month ago
and then they released a statement with
people being like we want what's best
for all of our grandchildren including
uh this one let's let's jump to this
story from timgas.com
twelve-year-old kicked out of Colorado
classroom over Gadsden flag patch the
student returned to school Tuesday
saying he would sit in to protest the
school's decision this story has been
going viral all day don't tread on me on
his backpack in a viral video you can
actually hear the teacher in this tweet
from Connor boyak he says meet 12 year
old Jaden was kicked out of class
yesterday in Colorado Springs running a
Gadsden flag patch which the school
claims his Origins with slavery the
school's director said via email that
the patch was disruptive to the
classroom environment oh man this is so
much to talk about here uh not only are
they uh saying that the the Gadsden flag
was a symbol associated with slavery
they came out later saying actually it
was about the guns and stuff he had on
on his back and so now they're trying to
change what actually went down because
there is a what appears to be a secret
recording of what was going on it seems
that this family was well aware of what
was going to happen now of course if he
had a I don't know a communist symbol on
his back they wouldn't say anything a
lot of people have said if he had a
pride flag they'd cheer him on well duh
but if he had like an actual communist
Soviet Union flag on his bag they would
say nothing despite like I don't know
the hundred plus million people that
were killed by the Soviet Union and if
you want to count everybody including
you know uh communist China it's uh
fairly substantive I just want to say
for the gas and flag we got one hanging
in the garage and it's basically a
symbol of Independence well I mean we're
talking about a teacher right somebody
that should know this stuff she said
that this there were Origins for you
know the Civil War and slavery and so
this is actually had the the Gadsden
flag originated in the Revolutionary War
uh this isn't anything
this shouldn't be a shock to anybody but
we keep going back and back and back and
we're gonna we're gonna relate anything
to slavery like I I I worked in real
estate before and you know people were
we had to change the name from master
bedroom to uh to primary bedroom or
something like that it's like we keep
more and more keeps getting sucked into
this slavery talk yeah and even if it
has nothing to do with it it's crazy
yeah Darth Vader was a slave to the
emperor he called him Master plenty of
times it wasn't neither of them were
black dudes it doesn't matter like
slavery exists on Earth deal with it
even today I don't think this is
glorifying slavery this is like get off
my back let me be an independent human
this kid is what he's 12 so he's in like
the fourth grade seventh grade maybe I
don't know
it probably was not disruptive to any of
his classmates it's disruptive to the
teacher who decided they didn't like it
who then pulled him out of class and
said you can't be here we have to bring
your mom in I love the secret video
because the mom is clearly sticking her
cell phone into her stroller she's got
like another small child there I think
this is such a strange example of adults
having actual hysteria rather than
really monitoring what's going on in the
classroom at all they're they're once
again putting their will and their
political agenda above everything else
the question though is it cool for his
12 year old sixth grade I assume sixth
grade to going to school with guns a
shirt with guns on it that says
Revolution
is that cool I mean different schools
have different rules about that type of
stuff like whether you can like have a
shirt with a gun on it or whatever else
the the thing is he didn't they they
have this recorded video it's the gas
and flag and then they're like we've
changed our mind actually this was the
complaint in the recorded meeting
remember when the kid chewed the
Pop-Tart into the shape of a gun and he
got in trouble for it yeah yeah these
schools are psychotic it's cool like
kids used to get in trouble for you know
if you're like playing like cops and
robbers on the playground when I was a
kid make
you get the plastic orange cap gun with
the little metal and then you get the
the roll of the red tape thing and then
and then we also had the the little caps
which were plastic uh like a plastic uh
what would you call it uh um
and then you you'd put it in and close
it it would go pop pop pop pop pop we
had those now what a kid choose a
Pop-Tart and he gets kicked out of
school a kid's gotta get it's gonna keep
happening these cap guns since the the
you know what the 50s yeah they didn't
have orange tips on them for a long time
exactly let's be real high schools just
have shooting clubs I mean it's just
it's all going in One Direction right
then you see these there's a video I
just watched of a guy in uh where was he
I think it was in California he's
walking up to his doorstep with his keys
to enter his home and guy you see guys
in masks follow him up and then just
start beating the crap out of him and
Rob him and it's just like man you know
that stuff could have happened at any
point in history but now we're living in
very dense urban areas where these guys
know they can be armed because they
don't care about the law and you can't
and this is this is we're at schools
there I I wonder if it's a natural
tendency of densely packed Urban
environments that result in this because
we had the story from uh uh sultanitson
about uh from the gulag archipelago that
you know a guy was being threatened but
with by a knife so he fought the guy and
then stabbed the the attacker got
arrested and then when he was on trial
he was like the guy was going to kill me
what should I have done and they're like
you should have run it's like so the so
when you have a criminal who's armed and
going to kill you well that's crime but
if it's you you're the good citizen you
should know better when I look at these
schools and how they're there they all
move in the same direction history is
bad I wonder if it's the average person
is docile ignorant uninterested in
worldly Affairs and just goes through
the motions and which means unless you
as a politically thinking individual
someone with passions and and and
opinions if you are not actively pushing
back defending say the Gadsden flag it
all get it's erased and we are moving
now into that era where you there are
videos of people being victimized and
the victims get arrested like you know
that guy Daniel uh Penny I think his
name was in New York there's Perry and
Penny I want to confuse them we're in
that because
good men did nothing as the saying goes
and so the lazy uninterested people take
the path of least resistance now we see
it take form take the shape in police
departments the cops the cops are
looking at these mass lootings and these
robberies and they're like I can't deal
with that
so what do they do nothing but then when
you are uh you know let's say filing a
legal challenge to an election well the
cops absolutely had no problem doing
their duties to arrest Donald Trump I
saw that video when Trump was being
arraigned I don't know if a rain he was
being arrested in Georgia and the cops
are in front of and behind him and I'm
like these cops are trash they are
willing to do it it is the easiest thing
in the world hey do you want to arrest a
guy because uh you know he's got a like
he didn't pay child child support yeah
sounds easy do you want to go arrest a
guy who's an armed robber who's
threatening to murder people now I ain't
doing that and that's where we end up
and they could okay because I mean you
look at Georgia Fulton County especially
you have this D.A this woke D.A this
this George Soros funded D.A that is you
know going after Donald Trump and and
it's not even just Donald Trump it's all
these other people you had the chair of
the Georgia Republican party which all
he did was his crime was proposing a
separate set of electors okay just in
case it was proven that uh and I I don't
I don't remember his name was David
something just in case it was you know
there was evidence that was brought
forward to you know possibly challenge
the election results in Georgia and you
also had uh funny Willis which I mean
I'm gonna I'm Gonna Keep with Fannie
Willis because I mean it's really funny
I mean I'm going to continue with
Fanning and you know she came out and
she actually posted after the 2020
election saying that hey you know why is
it taking so long for these results to
come out why are we doing ballot dumps
at three o'clock in the morning even she
was asking those questions is she gonna
prosecute herself what's going on
I don't think what she did was illegal
you're allowed to question elections
right what she's doing to Trump is
constitutional yeah well she's a
hypocrite that's my point but but this
is this is where we are all of these
things are tied together
symbols of this nation's history are
being banned in schools
right there there since the 1619 project
since before that they have been lying
about what this country is based on what
it's about and why we have these symbols
and you know what happens
I saw this tweet from I don't know this
person is some woman saying I'm so sorry
I offended you apparently she had gone
on Facebook and said puberty blockers
are a trick by pharmaceutical companies
to harm children blah blah and then it
resulted in the big backlash and she
went I'm so sorry please oh you
spineless piece of garbage come on this
is the problem how can you know that
Injustice is happening and evil is
rising and just be like I better
apologize and get on my knees for evil
just it's just it's just disgusting
they're afraid to get canceled I know
but but
they're letting evil win
for their own selfish pathetic reasons
what was Martin Luther King's quote I
think is the only what all that evil
needs to succeed is for good men to do
nothing that wasn't uh that was some
really historically that was the quote I
was referencing yeah and uh meaning that
you don't have to do good to make the
world good you just need to stop evil
when you see it or speak or call it out
so that Society the left used to be
about this too Edinburgh
I mean who was it John Lewis that said
you know get into good trouble right
what happened to that I mean it it it
you know we're talking about the right
you know calling things out calling
things out as they as they should be you
know such as you know if you see
election fraud how about you know call
it out yeah it's really weird when you
have ballots coming in and you know by
truckloads at three o'clock in the
morning okay why not question that is
that not allowed to be investigated at
this point you're going to end up in
jail because all this is now is an
intimidation tactic and people are going
to be afraid to say anything in the
future and that seems to be the goal
yeah I think it is the goal because I
don't think it's about morality of I was
like you're saying if there's election
fraud you should call it out because
that's wrong and that hurts the system
blah blah blah and they're saying that's
true if it benefits our team because
everything comes down to these two
parties that have to control Power and
ultimately you know what about it so it
might actually be John Stuart Mill they
say the admin writer says Edmund Burke
is a false attribution because no one
really knows exactly but of course the
phrase the saying is the only thing
necessary for evil to try them is for
good men to do nothing and John Stuart
Mill allegedly has a quote where he said
uh where is it at bad men need nothing
more to Compass their ends than that
good men should look on and do nothing
there you go amen
and that's that that's what bothers me
about everything these people who
would would watch the world burn
so they can sit among the ashes it's
like well I'd prefer to try and put the
fire out there's that there's a I think
it's a Sun Tzu quote I could be wrong
that evil men will burn down their
Nation their their country so that they
can rule over the ashes and weak men
will watch their Nation burn so they can
sit among the ashes for what purpose
would you I ask you citizen for what
purpose is do you have to sit among the
ashes of a fall of Fallen ruins you're
not going to survive I know that's the
thing you'll experience no joy like the
Phoenix must burn to be born again like
dude the Phoenix is a fantasy art
character you don't burn your city down
to make it better that makes no sense
it does they're not burning down their
city they're burning down your city
right your city is in opposition to
their world
so I guess if you can like sneak into a
foreign country that you hate and want
to see destroyed and then act like
you're a protester of that country and
get there to burn their own cities like
the CIA Yeah Tim who is running this
country I want your opinion on that
who's running this country at this point
because I mean Joe Biden is clearly not
running this country he's he's not
nobody's running it nobody's right so
we're no I think there's uh uh various
and disparate factions of powerful
individuals who are fighting over power
I think some people are more responsible
for the destruction than others but I
think ultimately
you do have Republicans you've got some
that are anti-establishment some that
are uniparty neocon establishment you of
course have powerful Democrats
their interests align in certain areas
you have the world economic forum and
their interests you have NATO
no one is controlling everything in this
nation there are just different Power
bases that influence different sectors
of the country some being more powerful
than other the most powerful block of
course is the woke establishment these
are the people that want war in Ukraine
support it and also you know want to
sterilize kids it's a weird amalgam of
people they are not the most powerful
Northern control of everything that's
exemplified by the fact that Bud Light
actually is taking a massive hit and
businesses can go under if we don't buy
their products if we were actually in a
totally centralized totalitarian state
then the woke establishment we'll just
would be able to snap their fingers and
there's no question their beer the beer
for Bud Light is bought and anyone who
spoke up would be gulagged we're not
there yet so it still is various uh
Power centers in the in in this country
Joe Biden does have the reins to one
portion of it
but uh I I can't say for sure I do think
it's fair to say the woke establishment
controls the most and this includes
neocons neolibs and the left but I think
they're actually losing control which is
why they're engaging in Acts of
desperate unconstitutional indictments
Etc they're going to lose the cultural
front so the only thing they can do is
Swing the hammer that they're holding
for the time being who do you think's
running the show
so I'm not I'm not exactly sure and it's
really hard to say I think that there
are uh I think you know somebody like
and I know we're we're you know getting
into really specific things here but
like Jake Sullivan you know National
Security advisor for uh Joe Biden uh he
was National Security advisor I believe
for Barack Obama as well there are a lot
of Obama holdovers there's a ton and
they keep bringing them in yeah I might
have special counsel every single one of
them has been affiliated with the Obama
Administration and so you're like okay
how did that get to that point okay you
know was it how much involvement does
Barack Obama have in the current
Administration uh because you know all
the policies seem to be you know echoing
Obama policies as well and you know I
can't help but think that this man I
mean are we actually looking at a a
third Obama term Jake Sullivan you
mentioned he as far as I know he's the
guy that Hillary sent most of the emails
to that were classified of her thirty
thousand emails or so so many of them
were cc'd to Jake
Afghanistan withdrawal as well so I mean
the guy is a disaster but he is pretty
much running you have Lloyd Austin right
which is supposedly running the defense
department in reality it's Jake Sullivan
he's the one calling the shots and it's
uh it's it's it's scary because he was a
disaster during the Obama Administration
he's in a he's a disaster now so I'm
glad we're calling out his name yeah in
his face because this guy up to this
point hasn't people need to know yes
Jake Sullivan no
what are you doing Jake I think that's
the thing everyone talked about when
Obama or when Biden was campaigning that
how much of this would just be the third
Obama term and did we want that right
but Biden consistently proves that his
administration is is headless right he's
not a strong leader himself I think
there's obvious signs of tension within
the administration and from what I felt
like I just said uh they the the third
white house uh council is stepping down
to be replaced with yet another person
who was in the Obama Administration so
they are falling back on an
Administration that hasn't been in power
and also
not creating any leadership among
themselves so we are not seeing
Solutions we're just seeing a scramble
to try and go back to what they might
refer to as the good old days with no
true Effectiveness it's like a rule by
Committee in the executive branch which
is where you're not supposed to have a
committee you're supposed to have a
president and the committee is Congress
you got the legislative branch for that
so we don't we don't need a committee
this pushing Biden's hands around
but they know that they have full
autonomy at this point because Joe
Biden's not hiring and firing anybody
you know they have full autonomy they
can do whatever they want to do so that
is the scariest part let's talk about
the story from the Daily Caller House
GOP will launch probe into Biden
administration's response to Maui fires
I would also just add they probably need
a response into the Hawaiian
government's response to the fires as
well as the Lahaina and Maui
governmental responses to the to the
fires because a lot of questions there
they said the house oversight and
accountability committee will conduct an
inquiry into the bite administration's
response to the fires which began on
August 8th and completely devastated the
town of Lahaina the federal response to
the Calamity has drawn intense scrutiny
from locals and the media who have
slammed Joe Biden's response so uh what
did he give him uh look at this people
flicking him off screaming at him
cussing at him here he comes after 13
days what do you do he gave everyone 700
bucks is that it yeah so we give him
originally they said that they were
going to give everybody that was
displaced both you know physically and
economically they were going to get 700
and more that was the original promise
to the people of of of Maui uh because
you know you got to keep in mind that 70
to 80 percent of Maui's economy is
tourism and originally the government
both the state and federal government
said don't come to Maui Maui is closed
okay so all these people lost their jobs
I'm over there
staying in a hotel in one of the the
biggest tourist areas in Hawaii and
there's nobody there it's empty it's
quiet there's so all these people
they're all they've all been laid off
and and then FEMA you know walks it back
and says well we're no longer giving you
money once the Press uh the Press
pressure went away they started walking
it back and so you know what people
there want to know is why why why does
the Biden Administration have to be
forced to do anything and 700 hours in
Hawaii everything in Hawaii is extremely
expensive that's like a half weeks pay
for most of these people and a lot of
these people have lost everything and
you know they work two and three jobs
and they've lost two out of those three
jobs
it's it's so infuriating to so many
people there but they don't want to
speak out because they're afraid afraid
of what they're afraid of of
repercussions because the I'm going to
be honest with you my experiences with
the Hawaiian government with the Maui
government
they're one of the most authoritarian
governments in the United States okay I
had a run-in with the uh the mayor of
Maui and I posted that video it went
pretty viral got you know uh like 15
million views or something like that
where I started pressing him and he had
his police force there put me in a
headlock so that I could not continue to
ask him questions all the other media
were allowed to ask him questions I was
not allowed to because I was asking
tough questions
he they do not want to be held
accountable they are afraid of looking
bad because these politicians they these
are their goals here it's to get elected
stay elected and get elected to higher
office what were you asking him I was
asking him what what was going on they
know okay they found 115 cadavers at
this point they know how many of them
are children and I had uh I I had
experts that were coming to me and
telling me like Pathologists that were
saying it's very easy to identify if you
find a a corpse you can identify whether
or not that was a child you can go back
2 000 years and be able to identify
whether or not that corpse was a child
they're hiding that number because
they're protecting their own butts
that's all they're doing there's two up
one to two thousand people quote missing
right but it's been like two weeks I
mean it's not the Assumption just to say
those people are dead so I went there I
was there for uh 13 days okay that
number went from 110 it's now at 115.
the death rate yes and now we're talking
you know there's still you know between
800 it depends on which list you're
looking at you know 800 to 1 000 plus
people that are missing okay
where are they when are we going to
declare
you know other people dead I mean yeah
exactly that's an intense heat bodies
melt yeah this is well there'd be
skeletons I worked at Ground Zero well
the bones melt I was working at Ground
Zero and the firemen would come into 911
I worked there after the cleanup and the
firemen will come in it was so hot under
the pile molten steel flowing and they'd
be like yo they think we're gonna find
bodies they find Wet twizzlery substance
that's all that's left over sure and if
there's a fireman jacket you know it was
a fireman because that's heat resistant
and they'll wrap it up in a flag but
that's it that's all you find in the
rest of it's liquefying and going into
the East River sure and it might be but
here's the thing that they're doing they
are hiding information that they have
because they're waiting for it to go
away they want the media to go away
because the media can only stay there
for so long right it's very expensive to
stay in Hawaii so uh if it turns out
that 2 000 people burn to death because
government didn't give the water like
this I've heard and you confirmed it
before the show but tell me about it
that people within the Hawaiian
government the Maui government
withheld the water from the fire
department so they could not put the
fire out right because you know their
whole thing out there it look the
Hawaiian government the Maui government
they're they're very liberal okay it's
it's one of the most liberal states in
the U.S you think California's liberal
Hawaii is two steps to the left from
there I mean it's crazy and so you know
we're talking about
one of the reasons that the fire got so
bad is because they don't do any sort of
fire management out there it's because
they want it to be natural just as the
land you know as it was before that's
that's the government you have all these
people lobbying the government for that
reason we're not talking residents we're
talking environmental groups that have a
lot of power out there uh and so they're
they're diverting water away from these
towns and so you have people that were
more than capable even firefighters that
lived in Lahaina that were unable to put
the fires out in their own houses
because there was no water there wasn't
enough water that was being sent to
Lahaina and so you have firefighters
that are on scene that can't do anything
at all they can't put out the fires they
have no ability I heard us I've heard
this rumor going around a lot of people
talking about it that they set up a
roadblock to get out yes and people were
turned around to go back into the fires
but some people just broke through the
barricade and ignored it those are the
ones that survived is that true that is
100 True wow that is why you see the the
videos of on Front Street that is the
main road and it you know just being in
Lahaina for uh you know 10 days I was on
the ground there you there's one Road in
one road out okay you if they're
blocking that road you're not going
anywhere why were they blocking it they
were because there were downed power
lines okay but here's the thing you have
Hawaiian Electric coming out now Maui
County assuming Hawaiian Electric saying
that their power lines sparked the fire
okay whether or not that's true is you
know a different argument but
when the roads were blocked the Maui
County government was saying that the
power lines were electrified okay that's
why they couldn't let anybody through
that's their claim now when Hawaii
electric is saying oh yeah no they
weren't electrified at that point
there's no reason that these people
couldn't have gone through
so but the people that did break through
the barricades and drove over those
lines they didn't have any sort of
effect from it the effect that they had
was that they survived the other people
burned in an Inferno and you know so it
sounds like the government's making a
false claim that the power lines were
active so there's a barricade what was
the barricade do you know so I mean they
had cops that were blocking the road but
at a certain point the fire got so bad
those cops had to flee too right yeah
well so when but the people that were
near the end of the barricade are you
know closest to the end of that row they
were able to
um it was blocked all the way through
the fire actually but they were far
enough away the cops were far enough
away that you know the people that were
closer to the front of the line they
ended up uh surviving the fire it was
the people that because the line was so
long yeah that it's it's it's a two-lane
road going all the way all the way back
the people that were near the center are
there buildings on both sides of the
road or is there access to water so this
one so all the roads were blocked let's
make that clear but the the Front Street
which is the main road there in Lahaina
that one was blocked as well that is the
main road I'm saying to the right water
on the so if you're driving out of the
town you had water on the left side so
people I'm assuming got out of their
cars and jumped into the water some of
them were bailing but some of them that
were bailing into the water also died
because it was too late the fire was
already engulfing these buildings we had
a lot of wind yeah and that fire was
crossing up to the water a lot of people
don't realize how hot fire is no joke
obviously you've had a campfire and you
felt the Heat
stand in front of a building fire and
the fire can extend a hundred plus feet
and it's you're like whoa and you're
backing up right when I was I told the
story about when I was in Ferguson
driving down the road seriously like a
hundred feet away from a burning
building and inside the car with the
windows up it felt like my face was in
front of a a campfire and I was like
damn like we gotta move that's too hot
it's crazy in this we're talking 80 mile
an hour winds that are right blowing the
heat into you people you you're saying
people burn to death in their car
waiting to get out yeah and held at a
stop by the police and they burned to
death while they were waiting absolutely
yeah that's exactly what happened and
that's why they don't want to talk about
this that is why they're trying to brush
this all under the rug because there
were so many people that died in their
cars there are children that were found
in like car seats in the car very young
children that were burned to death they
found the cadavers and you know that is
a that's infuriating the people
especially residents that were there
like their children
were killed because they were burned to
death because the government is totally
inept on every single level we do have a
super chat Jack Fox is saying bones
don't melt or burn after a person has
cremated they're put into a what is it
what it says uh they're put into a
machine that pulverizes them into dust
wow I've never I've never I don't know
someone in fact actually they soften man
look it up this reminds me of Uvaldi
where the cops wouldn't let their people
go in to save their own kids and they're
like no you can't it's too dangerous
we're gonna make we're gonna not go in
at all what in the look you at some
point get out of the way they don't
bones don't burn during cremation is
what I'm seeing wow look at that yeah
and these people I'm telling you right
now so one of the biggest things that
happened here you know first of all
blocking the roads I'm sorry if I'm a
cop and I see an inferno that is about
to come incinerate
hundreds of people that are trying to
drive down the road I'm sorry I don't
care what the commander is saying I'm
moving out of the way well these but
these cops are evil they thought there
was an electrified power lines they
actually were probably given bad
information
I don't care you drive over a a live
power line slow enough you're fine I'm
sorry they're gonna they're gonna
survive that more than they're gonna uh
survive at Inferno I mean I'm sorry I'm
gonna let you do what you want to do if
you want to drive around in the grass
people were able to do that drive around
in the grass I'm not gonna stop you
uh and you know a lot of these cops they
are now still simping for the County
government and it's crazy it's like do
these people they have no shame
what is it at some point you have to not
a single Maui cop has come out and
spoken out against
uh what happened they probably have
immense guilt that they murdered those
people absolutely yeah and people need
to be in jail for this people absolutely
need to be in jail well especially the
Maui Emergency Management uh
administrator okay because this is the
guy that decided that he wasn't going to
turn on any of the sirens he was going
to uh he said that if we turned on the
sirens and people were gonna come out of
their houses and then we're gonna run
uphill into the fire I'm sorry but I
don't believe that the people of Ohio
were stupid enough to walk out of their
houses and run into a burning Inferno
I'm sorry I have the sirens at all if
not to worn about fire right if you go
on Hawaii uh the Hawaiian government's
website you will see that it says uh the
sirens are multi-purpose they're
supposed to be used for Dam breaks
terrorist attacks wildfires uh tsunamis
all of this stuff I mean there's a
laundry list of things so based what
they did he got up there and lied okay
so if if anything he's guilty of
negligent homicide
okay because it was his decision that
ended up killing all of these people all
these these elderly folks and children
the adults that lived in the town like
the parents uh because I said they work
two and three jobs they're outside of
the town they work in the tourism
industry so they're way outside of the
Town they're in other parts of Maui and
you know uh it's you know probably 45
minutes away that's where a lot of them
work so they couldn't get back there in
time especially because the roads were
blocked I I I I mean it is it's
infuriating but again they're trying to
brush it under the road what time did
the fire start so it was about
mid-afternoon uh and so that's why
that's why a lot of these parents were
at work they couldn't get home to their
children and schools were closed why
because the power was out
which goes back against Maui County
government's argument them saying that
oh well the fire started because in the
and the lines were live when the fire
started that could be why the power's
out right well because they shut the
power down lines went down started a
fire yeah they shut the power down so
three o'clock in the morning the night
before is when the power or when the
line started going early that morning
yes so we're talking so there was a 10
hour difference and then one of the
brush fires started about one uh 1 p.m
okay so we're we're talking 10 hours
here
and so and then they said that 1pm brush
fire was 100 contained they sent the
firefighters to another part of Maui uh
takula uh which is probably about 45
minutes away Two fighter fire out there
so there were no firefighters for the
most part in except for off-duty ones
that were in Lahaina at that point that
100 contained fire ended up spreading
ferociously throughout the town there
was no water there were no firefighters
what are you gonna do about it
so I I my guess is I would have went
into the ocean I mean it's not like I
did see a video of people that went into
the ocean and survived 10 hours in the
state during smoke too yeah so the smoke
inhalation could still get you I mean
that was the crazy thing watching these
videos of people standing in the water
and they are in a cloud of smoke so it's
possible that some of the missing people
older people yes there are a lot of
people that have died washed away in the
water yeah because you pass out you're
in the water you pass out from smoke
inhalation you're gonna drown because
you're gonna fall down you're in the
water and then you get washed away and
people don't find you they will not find
you they and they're trying they are
actually down there there is a big
search effort in the water still to this
day uh from the day that I left I was
there three days ago I'm going back this
week uh and they have a huge surf search
effort in the water but the death count
still hasn't gone up because they're not
finding any bodies in there they know
people died in the water this is the
this is the problem with uh chicken
ranch government chicken Nanny State
governing or chicken ranch governing
that the police say we know it's best
for you we won't inform you about what's
going on shut up and do as you're told
and then you die which Hawaii has had
very intensely probably always but
definitely in the last couple years with
covet they had some of the most intense
code restrictions and therefore had a
tested how compliant their population
was right I'm curious I don't know if
you can speak this but what's the
reaction from the islands around it I
mean like do the other communities
kind of pair at the same lines as you
know Lahaina did the best they could or
are they critical of how uh managed the
fires so it's actually very it's a very
polarizing issue out there uh they most
people even a lot of the the
democrat-leaning people that I've spoken
with out there are like this is a this
was a a catastrophic failure of
government you know the people that they
voted for they have totally lost faith
in these people uh these people got very
comfortable the mayor especially uh and
the governor of Hawaii both both very
liberal Democrats they got very
comfortable out there they thought
because it's a very blue State uh and
even the people that are typically their
voter base are now questioning whether
or not that's a that's a good decision
because they've gotten way too
authoritarian
and there's no sign of that going back
they are right now they are putting so
much pressure
on the people to try to maintain that
power maintain that grip on the
narrative that a lot of people are
waking up and that's honestly that's not
due to the name the mainstream media
that's due to Independent journalists
that are calling them out
I I keep thinking about how the cops
stopped people on the road where they
burned to death alive obviously they
were alive if they died but uh that's
the most I mean it's not like Soviet
lockdown because they weren't throwing
them in gas Chambers but like they held
them in a gas chamber yeah that's the
banality of evil yeah right the idea
that the individual cops didn't think
they were doing anything wrong they
thought they were doing something good
but in fact they are responsible for the
death of all these people if the cops
were not there
some people may have uh run over power
lines I mean who knows but a lot more
people would have just driven Out of
This Disaster Zone and survived well I'm
sorry I cover disasters that's what I do
okay I've covered tornadoes I've covered
hurricanes you can drive over live power
lines okay just don't you know don't
speed over it why
why can you drive over or why why is
faster worse well because I mean you you
risk shooting that that line up into the
frame of your vehicle and you don't want
to do that a live line but I mean you
have rubber tires you drive over it
slowly you're fine I mean hell you could
even go over you know I drive a Jeep 30
miles an hour over the line you're not
going to toss it up I mean you have to
be going really fast to toss that line
up it's not a good idea unless you have
to drive over it okay but I you know in
this in this case this I I I
refuse to believe that these cops are
stupid okay and that they saw these this
fire coming and
I I can't for the life of me even you
can watch the videos why would you not
let the people through you see the
videos of them continuing to block these
people even seeing The Inferno
incinerating
the buildings right in front of the
street that they're blocking
I I I can't fathom it
evil yeah it's evil is not just a
mustache twirling villain it is the
Dopey henchman being like I don't know
he told me to do it yes stupid
leadership I don't normally think of it
as evil but it doesn't mean they're not
going to get ousted but I I I don't mean
stupid leadership obviously there are
people here who are in charge who are
more likely to be evil I'm saying those
cops watching fires speed up upon people
and then being like nope you stay that's
evil you take an oath to protect and
serve okay you don't take an oath to
your commander that's okay that's that's
that's how it is these days do you know
who the chief of police is oh it's the
guy it's the same guy as uh what you
call it uh the wall swag is shooting
right yep what do you mean it's the same
guy same guy the same police chief of
Maui is the same guy in Vegas yeah but
he moved jurisdictions please get
recruited to like other Majors you know
you know what's funny it's like a big
conspiracy theory about it and I'm kind
of just like maybe this guy's really
really bad at his job which is why it's
following like you know when when he
gave you what do they say if you smell
crap check your boot does it they use
the actual you know they they swear when
they say it but we'll keep it family
friendly so this guy is just like really
bad at his job you see the guy that
ordered the cops to blockade the road he
probably is I don't know he has the
ultimate say
but so here's the other part they the I
I was unable to find the chief of police
the entire time I was able to find the
mayor one time which is why I I hit him
as hard as I did because here let's
let's let's pull this up let's pull this
up so uh casino.org for some reason has
a story Maui's Top Cop now in Spotlight
previously LED Las Vegas strip command
for LV MPD also there you go how this
guy is failing up is beyond me but
congratulations to him for constantly
getting a job and then you know dropping
the ball to say the very least what
happened in the track record you said it
was during that Vegas shooting that he
was the chief of police he was the he
led the the remainder of the releasing
District that includes the Las Vegas
Strip during which uh he played a key
role in the response to the October 1st
2017 mass shooting
and then is this like you said it was an
upgrade I mean obviously he lives in
Maui well right he's like I'm getting
out of here I'm gonna go we got a job
somewhere else and then this happens and
it's like man this guy should be fired
right right no he shouldn't have a job I
mean and in all the stuff changed career
career paths I feel like this isn't
working out for him you're right yeah so
but this has been this is not a story
that you're seeing in the mainstream
media all the time and and why okay why
are they not wanting to hold these
people accountable because this stuff is
going to continue to happen unless even
less we're talking about this a little
bit before the show do you feel like
there's any
um feeling among mainstream media that
you're not supposed to criticize like
FEMA people who rush into disasters
people who are like the emergency
response they're sort of protecting them
in some way they feel obligated to say
nothing because they're not supposed to
criticize people who are like the heroes
so to speak yeah so I like first off
I'll I'll start by saying that FEMA is a
disaster in and of themselves uh they've
always been I mean you look back as far
as Katrina and that's that's just how
they are they're not good at what they
do I mean they have a multi-billion
dollar budget but are still incapable of
all the disasters that I've ever covered
uh Mayfield Kentucky tornadoes wiped out
the entire town okay Eastern Kentucky
flooding wiped out entire towns there
too they come in they make big promises
and then they disappear once the media
attention goes away it's the same thing
here it's the same thing in East
Palestine they actually didn't even go
to East Palestine until we forced them
to go okay because you know these people
are are have been inundated by toxic
gases their soils contaminated their
water's contaminated and finally FEMA
comes in what's happening now
uh not really much FEMA kind of backed
out of the entire situation and they're
doing the same thing here they're
already starting to back out as I said
earlier where they made all these
promises of all this money for people
that were economically displaced and now
they're like well yeah we're not really
going to do that this is a this is a a
an executive branch agency okay they are
under the command of the president of
the United States so he has ultimate
jurisdiction over FEMA why is he not
doing more why is the FEMA administrator
like seemingly totally inept and funny
enough the FEMA administrator right now
her name is Deanna
something I don't remember her exact
name she was in charge of a New York
City's covid response as well which was
obviously as we know New York City had
one of the most disastrous coveted
responses in the country this is Deanne
Criswell Deanne Criswell yep she is
currently the FEMA administrator so I I
mean it's like what is it why are we not
taking this organization more seriously
we're talking about people's lives and
livelihoods is it that FEMA is only as
effective as the president
so I mean like I said the president does
a lot of power over FEMA why isn't he
doing more I'm sorry but people's lives
and livelihoods American citizens okay
the people that I am my first goal as
president of the United States would be
to
it's protect protect my citizens right
and and make sure that when you have it
this is no fault of their own okay the
people of Lahaina did not do this to
themselves okay so in my opinion the
federal government should be able to I
mean we're sending 20 what just like a
couple weeks ago 23 billion more to
Ukraine how come we're sending you know
a total of to the Lahaina residents
under two million dollars in relief Aid
to them what would FEMA do like I did a
little uh Hurricane Sandy I did some
Cleanup in um Staten Island and it was
like flooding so we brought water
blankets
um what else would FEMA do there's mold
everything was molding so they had to
clear out all the moldy stuff but like
what more is it just only so much that
they can do and then they're like we
were Tapped Out sorry for the false hope
or is it that they're just not doing
what they can do like what could they do
to help these people in Lahaina well
first off they give fall soap every
single time every single time they get
involved in anything it's false hope
okay people see FEMA coming in they're
like yeah Emma
FEMA is I I mean they're not under
fonder they have plenty of money they
have plenty of money but so right now so
August 25th was the deadline for uh
housing okay so if you were staying with
a friend or if you were displaced by
FEMA okay and you were uh it's staying
with a friend or so not displaced by
funeral displaced by the fire okay in
Lahaina you had until August 25th to do
something about it okay if you're
staying with a friend or something and
you know you didn't react but you have a
lot on your plate if everything you know
everything you have is you know being
been incinerated
they're not helping you at this point
they're they're not giving you anything
they're not giving you the 700 or not
paying for your hotel room they're not
doing anything
why why is it where the only people that
are setting up the food banks giving
people clothing you know collecting
Goods water all of that it's all being
done by the community and non-profit
organizations every single person from
Lahaina that I spoke with
said the same thing the Red Cross is
useless FEMA is useless they don't even
try okay they have to go to individual
Community organizations so that's always
how it is yeah which is sad what do we
pay taxes for uh well modern monetary
Theory suggests that to control for
inflation they need to take money out of
the economy because as they just Mass
print it and use it for Wars at their
own discretion right then you'll really
that leads to inflation problems in the
underlying economy so they'll use taxes
to pull that money back out you said
this they were going to give everybody
700 and then they pulled that back or do
they actually give everybody the 700 wow
so they gave some people 700 they were
supposed to give people that were
likely displaced as well people that
lost like I said a lot of people there
have two and three jobs because it's 80
to 90 tourism is the economy out there
uh those people that were economically
displaced that were fired that were laid
off whatever they didn't get anything at
this point so they are struggling to get
by and so some people very few people
ended up getting that 700 that added up
to under 2 million 1.9 million is is
what they ended up paying out the uh
Hawaii a lot of people want to go to
Hawaii is now a good time to go because
absolutely right now is Maui is open
Lahaina is closed it's okay really go to
go you were just there like is it
amazing well so to be honest with you I
didn't do any I didn't see a beach I
didn't do I didn't do any of that
because you saw a lot of burned
buildings I saw I saw a lot of burnt
bill that that's what I was doing but
where I was staying was typically
because it was the cheapest area in
Mount or on Maui at this point was the
tourist area because there is nobody
there uh this is where all these people
worked in these massive Resorts and
stuff I stayed in a I'm not going to say
it because I'm going to go back there
but a very small motel
um and you know there is a Beach it was
beachfront I never stepped foot in the
sand or anything but there's nobody
there nobody at the beach nobody in the
tourist area these people need in order
to recover and any of them will tell you
that at this point they need tourism
back so the fact that the government is
saying don't come to Maui is ridiculous
I'd like to see maybe a federal
subsidization of tickets to Hawaii from
the mainland to get people to go fly
there that would be cool so I will just
say Tim paid more to get me here than I
paid to go to Hawaii okay so it's cheap
so how much is it to get to why I'm back
roughly average 750 round trip from
Kentucky oh man from Kentucky crazy wow
that is a long that's 10 hours worth of
flying and you're saying that by going
on your Hawaii vacation you're actually
helping the victims of this you're doing
a public service by going on a vacation
to Hawaii doing your civic duty by going
on vacation exactly so I'm telling you
guys come to Hawaii do it I mean that's
that's exactly what needs to happen
right now because
not helping them uh the state
government's not helping them the only
people that can help them right now are
people that are traveling out there you
should go to a show in Hawaii I'm
totally down with that that's hot it's
not so easy to just pull off at the last
minute go to disaster zones
so come on guys so many people would go
there if we did it and now's the time in
Hawaii it would just be like me and you
in a van basically yeah it'd be pretty
rough how do you get a van there
it's not hard to like yeah it's hard to
take the studio you can't really travel
light but sometimes you know a show with
a couple of GoPros and uh it's not hard
to take like two cameras and hook them
up to a live stream that's that's not
that difficult and they have like
individual podcasting boxes so it can be
done off a laptop I tweeted about this
okay you go out to Hawaii and you look
at they have these fields that are next
to the airport there are thousands of
rental cars right now that are just
parked in the field and TR I mean pick I
rented a pickup truck out there for 35 a
day full-size pickup truck I mean yeah
Vans and everything and because there's
nobody there is it because people in
general fled the island because of the
fires so yeah because that that's into
the there weren't it's not like the
entire island is on fire Maui is a
number a lot of people just anywhere in
the island were like we better get out
of here it's a disaster but that's
because that's what the government told
them to do right oh so residents of the
island that were not in line have also
have also bounced yeah right yeah
because exactly that's what the federal
and state governments are telling them
to do is get out Maui's closed now so a
private visit to Maui right now is like
the hottest thing on Earth yeah but yeah
yeah absolutely that'd be so awesome I'm
just going to give you an example it
takes you it takes you at least two and
a half hours to get from one side of
Maui to the other it's a big island
there's a big volcano on it too big yeah
I went yeah I went to the top of it it's
nobody there it's a national park nobody
there like if you're ever gonna go Now's
the Time Now's the Time so when you go
back what are you gonna focus on uh so
the thing that I am the most worried
about here in in Maui is or if say on
Maui it's on Maui
um
well first off I'll just say the people
there are very they love their home they
love their home that that is one of the
things that
is one of the most polarizing issues out
there right now is because you have
these conspiracy theories talking about
oh yeah well they're trying to take our
land they absolutely are trying to take
the land
Lahaina is one of the most beautiful
towns that I've ever been in and I
travel across the world to cover stories
Lahaina is Oceanfront it's the water is
it's the clearest water I've ever seen
and all these developers have been
trying to get this land for decades but
a lot of these families have been there
for Generations so they are
they're very apprehensive they don't
want to sell it you can give them 10
million dollars and they don't care they
might be working two or three jobs but
they still don't want to sell their land
uh and the the saddest part about it is
now they're thinking because one of the
first things the governor came out and
said Josh Green
uh he came out and said oh yeah well now
the state's gonna buy all the land up
you know via imminent domain right
they're gonna block them private buyers
yep and they're going to give them yeah
developers I want to jump to this story
this is from wng.org Washington Jerry
convicts five pro-lifers I find this
story absolutely fascinating they say
the jury on Tuesday found the five
activists guilty of violating the
freedom of access to Clinic entrances
act authorities immediately took the
pro-lifers into custody they now await
their sentencing and their lawyers are
planning an appeal the trial which began
with the jury selection on August 9th
centered on the participation in a 2020
sit-in at a facility in DC where they
suspected an abortionist of Performing
illegal late-term abortions each of the
activists faces the possibility of a
possibility of up to 11 years in prison
three years of supervised release and as
much as 350 000 in fines
we've uh we've talked about the
escalating conflict culture War called
cold culture we're gonna call it and one
of the examples that we often give is
Colorado and I think Oklahoma right yeah
they border each other in one state
abortion is completely illegal and in
another state it is completely
unrestricted
which opens the door to some very
serious
troubles if say some a woman flees the
state where it's overtly illegal in
every respect into Colorado for the
abortion which is likely happening now
as we speak and then there is a
challenge from another individual says
no stop her she can't do it's illegal
what happens does Oklahoma send police
to stop the wound from aborting and
killing the baby because they view it as
murder or do they not view it as murder
what I find interesting with the story
about these activists is that if you
take the perspective that abortion is
murder and that this doctor may have
been performing late-term abortions you
have a story of Five individuals who
took no direct physical action to stop
an active murder from taking place
simply sat in front of a building where
a murder was taking place and will now
be going to prison for trying to stop
that murder again that's if you take
that perspective
that I gotta say it's very interesting
to me because it says to me I don't I
don't actually think uh conservatives
think it's it's murder and it was
actually there I I can't remember who
was making the argument it was actually
a pro-life Christian conservative who
said clearly there is something
different about it in that even pro-life
activists do not behave similarly
overwhelmingly there may be some
individuals who would view it completely
as the same same thing but for the most
part the political conservatives that
say it is murder
do not act like it is
so I'm wondering if you know for one
this is a crazy story and I'm mentioning
what you guys think and showing what you
guys think about I'm also interested in
and where we go from here considering
this I honestly think that I I think
that the whole I don't want a dog pile
on people that are so pro-life that they
think a one day old inceptive child is
the same holistically as a 17 year old
boy
um so yeah murder destroying a
fertilized egg at one day and killing a
17 year old in Cold Blood are very very
different and I feel like it's LARPing
to act like it's a murder why is it
different because it has no cognizant
sentience as far as we know so a person
who's like in a coma you can kill
no it has nothing to do with it I'm
talking about a one day old inceptive AG
Sac or whatever it is and then an adult
human
um they're just different so I find like
this Obsession but and you see it here
like I explain it to us I don't
understand what you're trying to say
well it doesn't know English it probably
can't do math I don't think it can even
speak it doesn't have okay
abilities but I don't think does a
six-month-old have that ability I'd have
to pull out the thing and look at it to
examine to see what all it's developed
at that point at six months but usually
by 24 weeks I think you've pretty much
become a human
so you're taking the vosh approach in
that babies aren't actually alive until
some point after they're already born
it's living tissues
so you're saying during pregnancy and
you're saying after birth just I'm sorry
you're saying after consent 24 weeks
after conception making sure we're not
talking about a two-year-old no uh six
six months six months four months I
don't know something like that well but
at some point it starts to become human
and it's still living I'd never say it's
not alive but whether or not it's a
murder depends on whether or not it's a
human being well the law the law yeah
correct so intentionally killing a human
life is not murder no it's not a human I
don't think it's a human until you know
six six weeks or whatever it's 24 hours
what is it uh and a blast what's called
a zygote
um
describing a human though all those
terms to describe the stages of
pregnancy are all describing what
eventually be is a human he's gonna say
becomes a human but
they're all ways to describe it from
Ian's perspective dogs are zygotes too
at some point so this is like an
undeveloped animal
so like here here's here's I I mean I
don't want to get into the argument over
abortion I'm more concerned the
political ramifications of these people
being arrested and their perspective on
it but uh I accept your uh uh
perspective Ian I'm not sure I
understand what you're trying to say I
don't think you've actually you've
accurately articulated in a way that I
or many people could understand I when
people say that abortion is murder I
think it is kind of like a LARP I I I
like people were in that building
getting killed in Cold Blood those
people would not be arrested well and I
could be heroes this is the point I
actually made these people believe that
a murder they claim a murderer taking
place so they sit down and hold hands I
I don't think they actually believe that
I I agree with you uh I do think that uh
babies are alive uh in the womb and all
that I do think you know at one day of
conception there is a human life there
that would be killed in an abortion but
there's clearly something different
about it in that these activists and
almost every single activist their
position is well another murder happened
today let's let's write it down I'm like
if when you see a video of store clerk
being robbed and the guy starts
mercilessly beating into the stick these
people are cheering and celebrating yeah
when it comes to this they're like let's
sit down in front of the building now
I'm not stupid I understand there is a
political climate here and these people
are trying to do the non-violence Civil
Disobedience which is the appropriate
way to protest what our society deems in
many respects acceptable well half does
not they're taking the non-violent
approach to a
conflicted issue in this country which
is in my opinion
non-violence of disabases the correct
way to address these things but they're
going to prison for it if you can't sit
down in front of a building and Link
arms will they trespasses yeah I was
gonna say is this a state that has one
of the the barriers so they're saying
that you they're they're within the
violation like yes they were in DC and
DC has a law saying you can't block
access to a clinic so are we are are we
getting to the point because we saw Jen
saki I don't know if you saw this the
other day you know saying that well you
know the the the the whole thing about
you know Democrats being a fan of
late-term abortions is misleading are
they starting to back away from this now
because this how we even got to the
point where there are a lot of Democrats
there are a lot of people on the left
that are okay with all the way up to the
point of you know a week before birth
okay with terminating a pregnancy so are
we starting to back away from that I
think I think a lot of people equate uh
supporting something with happiness I
think there's a lot of people that I've
talked to that are pro-abortion that are
not happy about it they support it they
want it to be legal but they don't get
joy out of it I think that's the more
Normie like normal approach when it
comes to being uh pro-choice
but
I think it's still there uh yeah I don't
I don't see anything backing away from
it I think because Roe v Wade's kind of
in the rear view mirror right now we've
talked about it less as a country but
it's going to come back it always right
now in this country Roe v Wade has been
overturned
some states have decided to outright ban
abortion some states have decided to
make it unrestricted Limitless the
Democrats of course lie endlessly like
like I've got to mention gen sackey says
nobody wants this but all of these
states you have I should say all of you
but many of these states are enacting
these laws
you may say you know oh people have
gotten arrested for you know non-violent
civil disobedience in front of these
clinics before but we're now at a point
where
the conflict may be coming 2828 to a to
Greater tension with like I mentioned
Colorado and Oklahoma bordering each
other and one saying absolutely not one
saying under under any circumstances
with stories like this
pro-lifers are being told there is no
non-violent Civil Disobedience path
towards resisting what they view as
murder my fear is what happens after
that because the last thing we want is
anything to escalate but the government
is going to put these people in prison
for sitting down in front of a building
how long uh up to 11 years I think it is
a 350 000 fine dude so up to you know
the courts may say you know a year or
something they may get probation but
either way we've got these people
blocking highways they get arrested for
it you've got these activists that do
the non-violent Civil Disobedience all
the time you had far left a storm one of
the Senate buildings storm the Capitol
Building previously for like Roe v
weight stuff banging on the Supreme
Court doors no problem you got far
leftists trying to burn down the White
House burning down a guard post in front
of the White House setting fire to St
John's Church what did we get from that
nothing
I'm like this is getting scary you know
that's all I can say there's got to be a
way with abortion to have this
conversation that is going to heal the
system because instead of being like
screaming no yes no that doesn't work
instead of being like murder murder
murder murder when it's not legally a
murder don't scream that it is because
it's not legally one hold on there are
some states where it is legally murdered
right now what happens so in a state
where it's not a legal murder and so
it's no point in screaming murder that's
not the way well but also so we'll take
an eight-month-old baby in the womb stop
right there stop right there this is the
conflict I'm actually talking about if
you live in Oklahoma it is codified that
you are that it is illegal to perform an
abortion so the people in that state
have stated by their own Democratic
processes
you cannot kill this baby
if you live in that state and there are
many people who live in many states not
have enacted these restrictions or total
bans they are saying it's murder and
they have made it completely illegal
other states have said the inverse it is
not murder and it is unrestricted
so you can't just say it's not a murder
now because some states are saying it
effectively is that's an interesting way
to look at killing but you're right but
where does this conflict go then if you
have that's why I'm saying this is a
federal uh question this is a question
under the 14th Amendment I guess it
depends on your definition of a
naturally born citizen because if
they're not born then the 14th Amendment
may not actually protect them but the
14th Amendment actually says something
to the effect of Human Rights not being
denied this work it's interesting yeah
because when you have an eight-month-old
baby and you look at it in the eyes and
it's looking at you you know it's a
human just but it's I've had friends
that were born premature but they could
have been aborted in certain States
illegally and I'm like but once you know
like that if you can know maybe you
would be less likely to want to do it
the issue right now that I bring up is
if Oklahoma says it's murder and it's
illegal and cholera says nope it's not
and you can kill the baby
this this something is broken in this
country you cannot have a nation where
certain jurisdictions determine a
someone a that human DNA and matter is
not worthy of Life rights and one state
saying they are this is a recipe for
exactly what we saw back in 1861. some
states saying you do not have human
rights while other states you said you
do have human rights this is this is an
impossibility they cannot these two
positions cannot coexist so there are 30
states where it is considered double
homicide if you kill a pregnant woman 15
of those States abortion is is fully
legal up to so it is murder yeah so I
don't understand how do you have that
double standard that's what I don't know
I've never understood that no is it are
you saying a 100 sure it's considered a
murder or is it just an illegal killing
of some sort like a man homicide
homicide murders of federal crime
homicide means human killing human if
you are correct in that if there's a
woman who's pregnant and you you know
you're drunk and you crash into them
they say you killed two people there's
two homicides it's a double homicide
they are saying a human killed a human
and that unborn baby was a human it
could be looked at as like um as a
manslaughter you know not necessarily A
murder murders of different murders like
a federal crime so I don't know it's
murder you're still I mean or even if
it's manslaughter I mean you're still
slaughtering a human that that's the
that's the whole point of manslaughter I
agree no no and I'm fairly certain in
the states you're referring to if a
deranged serial killer takes a machete
and goes to a pregnant woman and
butchers her killing both the baby and
the woman it is a double murder
she shoot the woman even if you just
shoot the woman I mean it's like because
it's yeah if the baby dies the baby is
going to die as a result yeah but like
if the woman kills her own baby in a
state where uh it's illegal is that
considered a murder at this point I
don't know that's the broken thing
right like a woman nobody's talking
about it well so my point is just this
activists performing not engaging in
non-violent Civil Disobedience face
prison in DC yeah what is this face act
it's you it's it's it's been around for
a while you can't block clinics but
that's I'm telling you like JFK said
those who make peaceful Revolution
impossible make violent revolution where
they really be blocking the clinic or
are they just sitting there sitting
there is blocking not really not if
people can walk by you or there's other
entrances
well I don't know look my point was that
these two concepts cannot coexist in one
nation a government cannot say
to a state you are allowed to determine
who is worthy of Human Rights sorry
that's a constitutional question
otherwise Colorado can say we hereby
decree Republicans don't have First
Amendment rights because we don't
consider them human dude and the 1964
Civil Rights Act exclude Communists so
you can have a red State say if you're a
communist you don't get constitutional
rights no you can't do that we need some
new a new Human Rights Commission of
some sort because you need to control
and own your own copyright of your own
Visage your own face and name and
likeness because companies cannot take
that from you that is you and we also
need to recognize that these little
babies are alive and they're probably
human and if we can neural net these
things when they're like at three months
old and you put the neural net in the
womb and you see all of a sudden they
can learn language they can communicate
with you when they're at two months
we'll realize a lot ahead of time like
that they're human and like Mozart but I
need the science to back it up I can't
just assume that a little zygote is a
human what else would it become yeah we
got to go to super chats so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button Chimera by the way uh
subscribe to this channel join us over
at timcast.com go to timcast.com click
join us to become a member and check out
the members only uncensored show which
will be coming up at just about 10 pm
you don't want to miss it and uh let's
read what you all to say
all right I'm not your buddy guy says
did you hear about the worm in a woman's
brain I did
um I glanced I scrolled past a story
about anybody know what that was about
no
someone had like a crazy big worm in her
brain or something like that oh my god
well you know it happens right
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim it will
never happen yup not happening Yep this
is what really what really bothered me I
was talking about this earlier the
question of will they remove Donald
Trump's name from the ballot
unilaterally well the Secretary of State
in some State like Michigan just say
Trump committed Insurrection his name's
off the ballot there doesn't need to be
a lawsuit they can just do it they'll do
it in October and then there will be a
lawsuit and then in December the Supreme
Court will say you can't too bad Trump
lost already and everyone keeps saying
it can't happen yet every single time
we've brought up uh oh they're trying to
do X someone goes that can't happen and
then it does we're at the point where
not only did Trump get indicted they've
gone after his lawyers and media per and
now they're investigating media
personalities so it's like
first I had trouble never get indicted
Trump won again remember remember Trump
won't get impeached oh I love that one
Trump book you gotta Beach twice then
they said he wouldn't be indicted now
they're indicting his lawyers okay yeah
do not be surprised I'm not saying it
will happen I'm saying it is there's a
strong probability and it is entirely
possible they do it
for people to be like nah that can't
happen oh absolutely this is the evil
men if if good men do nothing if you
just assume it can't happen you're one
of the good men doing nothing do not
assume that be vigilant well they all
act like they Trump can't possibly get
elected again he's unelectable or
whatever why are they going to these
Great Lengths to you know remove him
from the ballot in these states I mean
that is such a huge leap to when is the
last time this happened to a major
candidate has it ever happened before so
not that I know so why do they feel like
they have to do this why are they
setting new precedents I mean because
they have to ensure that he will not
become the president again they're
terrified exactly my guess is because he
wouldn't play ball with Swiss the Swiss
banks and they're afraid that he won't
oversee a smooth transition into a
totalitarian world government where the
United States is the lucky left arm like
no he's like no we are the head the
brain the force the Reckoning all right
let's we got one from Zana 520 says
because this was brought up last night
and as one of them Bronies started as
fans of a cartoon that wasn't just for
girls and was created by an old Cartoon
Network veteran things went downhill
from there but gen 3 was unique I have
no idea what that means I guess are you
implying that like the original show was
more like I don't know Ed Edd and Eddy
or something or Powerpuff Girls or
whatever like they were car or SpongeBob
like jokes in there that adults
understood or something I don't know I
think my little ponies was always for
girls even if it was a cartoon Cartoon
Network production
um but if you like have you seen all the
show I I haven't uh then there you go I
I can't say I'm completely informed and
I don't want the brownies to feel
isolated from IRL yeah but I sort of
don't believe look SpongeBob spawned a
bunch of memes that adults use because
often in these kids shows humor is
intended for adults because they want
the adults to watch it with their kids
they don't want them to go insane
basically they want adults to watch it
and the kids will laugh at the funny
shapes and the squirrel who's got too
many acorns or whatever and you know but
yay Patrick we saved the city and the
city's burning down that's like a meme
about like Democrats all the time you
know
nobody calls them spongebobbbies
unless they do I don't know maybe some
people are I guess no one's going around
dressed up like SpongeBob though so not
as part of a culture or something yeah
it didn't spawn the subject that uh yes
awkward costume Tyler Bratton says
breaking the Tennessee House and Senate
have adjourned the special session
without passing any gun control or red
flag laws huge win
I mean I guess with the government did
not screw us hugely yeah right yeah
exactly
I guess technically you know because
they're doing it so often it's like we
need government for emergencies on the
nose on the right away but then we need
them to back off and let us live our
lives and run ourselves how come this
was never a problem before I mean my dad
telling me that oh yeah well I mean I
used to have a gun in my pickup truck
when I went to high school you know like
things like that you know a shotgun
mounted to the bag like this is never
you never saw school shootings what
changed that's what I wanted Reagan shut
down the mental institutions in the 80s
well I look I'm not going to say I'm a
big Reagan Super Fan so let's uh all
right we got I don't know if that's no
reason Guardsman norheim says do not
send your garbage to my front door
please enough of you come up in the
summer sincerely Alaska resident we're
coming we're coming for your oil
fertilize your soil yeah we're gonna
we're gonna take the oil from Alaska
let's grab some more Super chats Stephen
Wolfe says imposter President Joe Biden
and Herbert the Pervert from Family Guy
or the same person pictures created from
AI are absolutely crazy
you guys know Herbert right oh yeah she
talks like this oh
yeah I got Harry
oh what do we got glucose donor says Tim
the concept of movie bias and criminal
justice is called the NCIS effect where
people think investigations are solved
in a day I love that that's funny all of
these shows like NCIS and Law and Order
they solve the crime well no to be fair
Law and Order actually has the dates and
it shows months in between but to NCIS
yeah it's like one day they catch the
murderer it's just like you got it guys
just every week they have a case and
it's over and they have like that 50
year old woman who dresses like she's in
her 20s you know what I'm talking about
that she's got the pigtails and she
wears oh the the uh she's like the
forensic scientist yeah but she's like
she's like 50. is she really yeah that's
so funny I don't know you can look it up
I like when they enhance stuff that's
like two pixels
4K is it Abby scuto is that her name I
don't know from NCIS I don't know she's
like the goth girl yeah yeah
what do we got
why why cases if Trump is removed from
the ballot could some states refuse to
certify their election yes because the
legislations could refuse certified
certified elections for a lot of
different reasons are they gonna put
them in jail uh if what if we can put
them in jail they refuse to certify the
election are they going to put who in
jail no I mean we're talking about you
know look at look down in Georgia you
know you you even question the
legitimacy yeah but this is different
we're talking about what Democrats are
willing to do versus what Republicans
are willing to do so will they refuse to
certify their their elections if you get
a state like Michigan and somehow Trump
wins then yeah they'll they won't do it
but Republicans they'll be like oh I
guess you win again Democrats
all right a rational says first time
superchat I live near the Colorado
Springs school I ordered 100 little
Gadsden stickers and plan to submit them
for donations to the kids force them to
double down or agree with Governor
pulse's tweet
interesting
bag says Cassandra I know you're out
there would love to see Mark judge on
the show and know what he's been up to
since the Kavanaugh dog and pony show
uh maybe culture war is a better show
for uh hanging out with Mark judge and
we've reached out to him before
and we're hoping to to book him but uh I
have no I I don't know what's going on
there what's he doing Mark judge yeah
well he invented Biebs and butt head no
that's Mike That's Mike Judge oh Mark
judge you're right that is Mike Judge oh
I'm thinking of the wrong guy oh oh yeah
Mark judge I don't know that I should
get both of them American Author
journalists known for books about his
Suburban Washington DC youth this is
Mark judge oh I saw him I saw MK and
judge and I just immediately thought he
was in about it because we were trying
to get Mike Judge on the show and we
should have Mike on yeah oh but Mark
judge for sure yeah well all right
whichever judge wants to come on you can
tell who I'm more interested in having
on the show to be honest I wanted to see
Mike Judge I'm like oh he's talking
about that guy like
I'm a big fan I was watching all the
newbies and buttheads they're really
good oh yeah I don't know there's two
new seasons that are out yeah it's wild
it'd be so cool to see him do the voices
like at the IRL table yeah he said he
knew a guy like Beavis he in school
growing up you're like laughing in his
desk yeah and then there's a uh I love
one of the new episodes they did Biebs
and Butthead are meditating and the you
know their hippie teacher is like clear
your mind so you can reach Enlightenment
and then all of a sudden their souls
just and lift up to the you know to
Shambala or whatever because their minds
are empty already it's great I love
being voted all right where are we at
anyway yeah sure Mark judge too for sure
what do we got by the fires that says
Rachel does make me wonder what happens
post Trump will folks go back to sleep
and let the Deep State just regroup
change tactics and carry on now the
people who are supporting Trump are not
necessarily all conservatives they're
anti-establishment and then there's the
default like so the lockdowns worked
because it got the um
the normies who don't pay attention Into
The Fray
without a lockdown or Force these people
are going to go back to you know
watching bar stool or something like
that no disrespect to Barstool like
people would prefer to watch they get
way more views people would rather watch
and uh Sports and talk about their their
pastimes and their Hobbies then the the
the Affairs of the political class but
people like you watching this show yeah
we're not going to vote for them and so
they know they need a way to force
Regular People Into The Fray they can't
keep doing it it won't work
Karen Reese says Karen Reyes I'm for Law
and Order so I'm 100 Trump look at the
BS in Maryland with Senator Jill Carter
who is blaming law enforcement and
prosecutors for misunderstanding the law
regarding not being able to charge juv
charge Juve
there's a funny story out of Chicago the
mayor is suing Kia I think he's suing
Kia saying that the the robberies are
the fault of the car manufacturers for
not having anti-theft instead of you
know the city oh yeah what is the reason
she got attacked her her outfit didn't
Seattle do something similar there
there's a couple major cities that are
saying like Kia this is your fault you
made your cars too easy to break into
and steal I kind of agree we're not
seeing this this is like a tick tock
Trend to break into Kia and steal them
we're not seeing this from any other car
manufacturer and I want to know it's
because they have the same part the
people figured out how to break into it
posted about it online and now people do
it all the time okay but why is it their
fault because well I I'm just being
honest with you I mean in Kentucky I I
would have never heard about this unless
it was happening in Chicago okay people
just it just doesn't happen Okay so you
get your crime under control Seattle is
sued in January I mean it's happening
Seattle is a liberal hellhole I mean
it's the same thing and it's soft on
crime Helen is completely right it's
that it became funny it's that it became
we don't care what the consequences are
this is a tick tock Trend and I'll do it
I mean it's the same thing every once in
a while these videos of people like
licking ice cream and then putting the
cap on and put it back in the freezer go
go viral and then for a while some
grocery stores kind of chain their door
shut or whatever there's a lack of moral
standing do you guys know what Ninja
rocks are no
uh so none of this stuff about Kia's
matters because there's a thing called
the ninja rock which I will not
elaborate further because you know it's
bad enough as soon as you talk about it
people can find out what it is but you
can effectively have this tiny little
rock that you flick at a car window and
the car window will shatter instantly oh
I know with almost no Force so uh you
may be familiar with those emergency
tools you just basically
it's got a seat belt slicer and a window
shatterer because if you're underwater
there's the pressure is keeping
everything locked you put this little
thing up to the window and click a
button and then it the window just chops
use it to right you know yep they walk
up to the car and go and then the window
just goes so people figure out how to
get them and it doesn't matter if you're
a key or otherwise like there's there's
videos you can watch where someone just
walks up those little things like that
and then the window just goes boom
sounds like you need to talk to Elon
about Material Science for 21st century
didn't you see the video where he threw
the can what do you call a cannonball or
something it was a yeah it was a big
steel ball he locked it out the window
of the the Cyber truck and so the Cyber
truck Windows bulletproof and then he
threw it it shattered yeah
you did it a few times somebody got
fired yeah I think the issue they said
was that it was propped up and it had
some countervailing Force against it or
something which isn't supposed to have
they hit it with a sledgehammer during
like testing and they cracked where the
window like the bottom of the window
where it's set in the car door and so
that all it took was the ball to finish
the job yeah
let's grab some more Super chats
Mad Rock Says in Colorado my son was in
kindergarten and did the finger gun pew
pew and was nearly expelled they have a
zero tolerance policy so a kid with the
guns on his shirt would be sent home
suspended Orcs build yeah that happened
at my elementary school kids got in
trouble for like doing the figure gun
thing we were not allowed to play with
guns as kids my dad wanted us to and my
mom didn't so it was like a no gun
policy at the house we didn't have toy
guns none of those we got Super Soakers
eventually the squirt guns but never
like the the plastic toy guns I don't
know if that's a good thing or a bad
thing like I grew up not being a gun guy
which is we all had toy guns in in a
bunch of different ways Super Soakers
were toy guns cap guns they have those
they have those water ball guns and
those jelly guns that shoot little balls
of jelly or little balls of water but an
airsoft I mean Airsoft a big thing
growing up I mean it's nothing in it
paintball Danny Danny engineer says why
do people keep saying Ian just started
lifting everyone on Tim cast IRL has
been lifting with me for six years
you're a great gym buddy Ian love you
you're welcome I see he's listening to
us while he's in the gym that's right
you're pumped dude today I just went for
it I was like why do I have to limit
myself to one hour a day in the gym
they're dudes that do six I can just I
just stay in there all day it's either
that or I play video games or I'll just
be in there moving yeah and eating and
then well building something what I
would what I would do on the treadmill
is I'd play Hearthstone
and then seriously I'd play a few games
and then I'd be like oh man it's been an
hour and 20 minutes and your body knows
what it needs next like you can tell
what muscle wants it to get to like
homeostasis
waffle Sensei says yes it was Sun Tzu
that was the quote evil men will burn
down their country so they can rule over
the ashes
yeah that sounds like yeah you know
magic GoPros as I lived on Maui for four
years it's horribly corrupt and
mismanaged remember the nuke alert also
on 911 they found the terrorist
passports intact
they did yeah that is a true fact they
fell out of the airplane after it hit
the tower and they landed on the ground
perfectly for them to find that's right
very convenient now everything else
burned up well the plane hit Pentagon
vaporized instantly no but on the
passport maybe it was like in the very
back in the cargo and it got blown out
by the wind before the vaporization
happened it's the most that is the most
ridic I'm sorry I don't want to go too
deep on it dude like they found the guy
they're like we found the villain's
passport that we want to be the villain
wait until the uncensored space yeah
I mean like
did they find any other passports like
there's probably a lot of documents a
lot of paperwork that were thrown about
when when all this chaos was happening
someone probably dropped a briefcase I
mean come on but the plane went into the
building and exploded in a fireball yet
Mohammed atta's passport was on the
ground there's nothing else left from
the plane there's not even proof that
yeah I mean like you don't see any other
portion of the plane in the Pentagon
have you ever looked into how they make
these passports they're remarkable they
got to be they got to be uh chain linked
to steal that's right yeah it's like
chainmail all right all right let's read
some more let's read some more Rolo says
do you think the police chief's
credentials from the FBI Academy raise
any alarm bells for you it's not as
LinkedIn and the FBI Academy is invite
only via nomination
is it really you can't be in the FBI
Island someone nominates you
you have to have a college degree it's
very important yeah there's like a big
interview process to get into the FBI
right so I don't know if invite is the
way I describe it but
all right Papa Romano says can Nick
elaborate on the black fences they have
set up around the burn area and the
unusual police presence protecting the
burn area
yeah so the so this is the thing like I
said that they're arresting literally
arresting residents that go past the
barricade I I made it about three and a
half steps past before you know the
National Guard ended up running up
really quickly the Hawaiian National
Guard uh to you know question me and
they pulled me aside look I got pulled
aside by Maui police multiple times I
got pulled aside by a Secret Service uh
apparently I'm on a list now because I
my TSA pre-check no longer works uh
after Hawaii so very convenient uh and
you know because I tried to cross into
the zone and this was
you know it's
now even now weeks later they are
putting up this black fence around
uh Lahaina and so so now you can't say
there was a fence before now they're
putting now they're putting the uh black
sheeting all the way around it so you
can't so you can't even see it uh and
there's a no drone zone now wow uh which
I my Dr I have an older drone so I'm
able to put it up in the end so I did it
the other day but so I was able to get
video but now
I don't understand it they're not
helping when it comes to the entire
thought that they're hiding something
they're not even attempting
to dispel that narrative so
wow
well let's grab some more
what we got rooster and the hen says I'm
with Ian we should have bodied Helen
Keller oh
bodied what yeah he's basically saying
that if you think babies you know aren't
alive unless they have some kind of
comprehension ability then Helen Keller
would be disqualified in your view I
didn't say that we should be killing
death uh infants or people that are in
the womb that are deaf or blind I didn't
say that is an infant a human
uh yeah an infant is post-birth
um no no I'm saying that the human brain
hasn't developed enough to have ears yet
at one day
I like Helen Keller so so let's just
read messages
all right Pony up says after 15 weeks of
stem cell researchers fail to abort the
fetal cells they harvest from there
Bound by federal law to consider them a
human being
interesting
well there you go
just leave me alone says I lived on Oahu
in 96-97 I got my first tattoo in
Lahaina I was amazed by the Banyan Tree
this breaks my heart for the Hawaiian
people murder
wow
I wonder what the recovery recovery time
is going to be like for the city I mean
now we're getting the idea that it's not
only years that we already expected but
also the government has to allow
anything to happen and that's the thing
government has to allow it depends on
what you mean by recover at this point
uh what I mean because they like I said
they're going to try to take the land by
eminent domain the governor has already
said that so I I don't know I mean
what's recovery selling it to a
developer having Resorts built on it
Matthew Garber says Tim you overstate
the militancy of the pro-life movement a
more likely inflection point for
interstate interstate conflict is
parental rights LGBT issues intrastate
or interstate I think Interstate
conflict is what we're talking about you
know like Florida Fighting among
Floridians fighting Floridians didn't
seem to make a lot of sense but uh I
don't overstate the militancy of the
pro-life movement in fact I am quite
literally understating it I'm saying
they don't actually do anything like
they literally think there's a murderer
but they'll go and sit down and just
hold hands
that's my point
all right Leon says you see the Pope's
side with the woke churches today
no I went I went to uh I went to the eye
doctor today I had to get a contact lens
prescription you got to do it every
couple years right did they puff your
eye they did yeah that's cool yeah
they'd blast it
so my prescription has not changed in
two years and my eyes are healthy and
we're all great and the reason I bring
it up is that when I was sitting in the
office waiting to pay they had a Dei
poster on the wall and it was the
weirdest thing that this eye doctor
insisted on informing me of their sexual
preference
I was like there's like a big picture
talking about like what they were into
it was like I was just really confused
by this poster was like diversity Equity
inclusion and what it means and it was
like diversity is when you you try to
figure out if everyone is welcome at the
party inclusivity is making sure they
can get into the party and you know like
Equity is making sure everyone's dancing
and then above it it was like gay
lesbian bisexual things like on a flower
and I'm just like I'm just not convinced
it's relevant to my eye doctor
appointment whether or not you sir enjoy
the presence of men or women I just
don't understand how does this change my
contact prescription
if I say I don't agree are you going to
make me wear glasses like is there like
a like a like a person goes in there and
says hi I'd like to get an eye exam and
purchase some contact lenses but I'm
concerned you don't sleep with men
doctor do you because if you do I'll
feel more comfortable here I don't
understand what the point is do you ever
get worried when you go to places like
this that you're going to be getting
sabotaged or whatever that you know
you're well it's time to go to like you
know because like say if I go to a
psychiatrist right because I have add
really badly right but I'm almost afraid
to tell them you know what I do for
everything and that you know I think the
the uh eye doctor as a corporate eye
doctor it was a chain I don't think they
know or care as to why that was put on
the wall by corporate okay I am not
going I ended up not buying contacts
from them though after I left I was like
you know what I'm just gonna order from
somewhere else and do a different
company because I don't want to give my
money then I like zenimax I haven't
looked into who owns them though yeah
but um if it's like a small business and
they have communist iconography I I
won't give them my money there's a
coffee shop out here and they had a big
sign saying mass is required and I'm
like Starbucks is across the street and
so I went to Starbucks Starbucks said no
Max require Master required and I was
like okay well I got Starbucks gets my
money then it is what it is
there you go if you want to make money
don't play that stupid game
all right we'll uh we'll just grab
another one here before we head over to
the members only
what do we got
vosh 1985 says this was the plot to an
X-Files episode which one the Wildfire
or something
I don't know maybe anyway if you haven't
already my friends smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show if you really do like it and
join us at timcast.com head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member the members only show will begin
in just a few minutes we can uh we'd
love to to have you there we're gonna
talk about things that are not so family
friendly and then you will call in we'll
take your calls you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast Nick do you want
to shout anything out sure yeah shout
out my uh my X account that's where I
post pretty much everything because I'll
probably get banned on any other
platform
um it's x.com Nick sorter n i c k s o r
t o r and you'll see more from Hawaii
here uh next week nice yeah I'm
interested to see what what you uncover
we're not letting this story die we're
not gonna do it and I'm gonna try to
convince Tim that to do a live show out
there with us so I'll set it up let's do
it Tim come on board uh I'm Hannah club
I'm a writer for timcast.com you should
follow Tim cast dot of timcast news on
Twitter and Instagram it's the best
because you work for me Chris Bertman
Adrian Norman Cassandra Fairbanks
McDonald's just everyone who's great uh
you should if you want to follow me
personally you can find find me on
Instagram at hannahcler.b and on Twitter
at HC brimlow thank you so much thank
you Anna Claire uh I'm Ian cross on
follow me on the internet get ripped get
healthy stay healthy keep doing it it's
non-stop it is your life dude thank you
Nick for going to Hawaii man thanks for
putting this on the map and East
Palestine too thanks for going there yes
sir we're going to continue doing that
because you know mainstream media ain't
gonna do it so well we're the mainstream
we're doing it yeah we're doing it this
is the evolution of media thanks
um you guys can follow me at Kellen PDL
on X I always see your posts I always
see your work Nick it's great to finally
meet you and we need more people doing
what you're doing and yeah go visit Maui
take a vacation take some time off don't
be so black pilled give them your money
all right everybody we will see you all
over at timcast.com in a couple minutes
thanks for hanging out